[ __ ] yeah hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to whiskers now
it may look like it on its surface but I
do not believe this is a five nights at
freddy's fan game this game actually
came out before five nights at freddy's
if I'm not mistaken but either way it's
only like it's it's own thing as far as
I know what this is is a point-and-click
adventure horror game that takes place
somewhere hello ru whiskers I think you
might be whiskers well why did you wake
me up there's your doing the villain
leaned on the way out
that creepy watch do that okay why am I
here why did you wake me up and then
tell me to rest doesn't make any sense
I'll take this God do I let me move the
chair oh sure I know
clunk let's see me I'm big smart in my
brain hold o me I'm no answer to this
puzzle but me I may not like what's in
the darkness when I ok good it doesn't
work okay well there is definitely a
well there's something move away in a
minute
wait do you see that there's something
moving in the darkness right there do
you see that oh you thought I wouldn't
notice you ha oh I'm all over you ok so
I need some kind of form of light or
something how am I gonna be able to get
in there if I can't I can't move that
again doors locked tight okay there's
something in there I know I see you move
in there
[ __ ] you sack of [ __ ] bag of ass dude
hi nice hat unless that's your head then
I'm sorry I apologize okay
alright then I'm just gonna nothing I
can take off you okay I'll be on my way
he is hiding great
let him stay hiding thanks for the heads
up I'm gonna go upstairs good God
all right funk let me make some noise
oh no Western man comes get me right
thunk thunk you're not trying to be
stealthy about escaping my prison cell
anyway here I go I can't lift that door
with my butthole all right so nothing in
there
nobody useless junk okay well can I take
that that saw looks the opposite of
useless that saw you look looks useful
looks like full of use
ooh that's odd there's no dust only on
that cover let me open it oh but I do
that that that seems like the gas thing
to do all right whatever okay so is
there like some tool that I need guys
super cold hands
by the way brand-new Christmas sweaters
on sale now Marga Blair comm links in
the description that wasn't a plan
promise it is legitimately cold then
these are cozy so I'm gonna do that also
I got a fleece blanket it's a blanket on
sale
Scott it's good blink
thank you got a logo on it's pretty cool
there that there there it is there it is
like a matador can't because gold I
don't know why they like this office
like usually I have offices that get hot
so I was like I definitely want an
office that can stay cool and it's
freaking frigid in here also I'm
bundling up da hi alright okay and if I
got a screwdriver please okay I can't
lift that door with my bare hands woman
so I couldn't use any of this obviously
useless junk here so I guess I'm just
screwed is it you guys here he's here
something doors lock tight okay
all right what happen to that crowbar
all right well I'm screwed aren't I no
there's got to be like some kind of tool
that I can get I can't seem to interact
with anything else so do you have
anything you got nothing you just got a
weird ahead okay all right okay all
right okay okay persistent pays you
didn't need to make that noise I would
have been spooked anyway all right well
he's around that's just how he sleeps
apparently he's like a bat or something
oh the boiler contains a small shiny
door key why why does it contain that
I'm curious honestly where'd the where
did he go there was nowhere else for him
really to go except in my general
direction so I got bad feeling about
that door all my suspicions were
confirmed this is the unhappy tour ah
filled with nightmares okay ooh can't
hide from me I know what I'm about yeah
friendly I'm in there's all now I must
be very small nobody make a joke about
that
thunk thunk knock-knock hi excuse me sir
ma'am excuse me
poor little fellow starve to death
[Music]
excuse me not safe or is that nothing to
fear totally safe nothing to fear
totally safe my friend that's what it
says there's nothing to fear don't leave
my friend that's what the whole message
is that's what it is
all right thanks thank you thank you
thank you very much about that I got a
bone because my first instinct if I'm
trapped in a place and I find a skull it
is what looks useful hard with this
Blanc er okay all right anyway gotta go
to the bathroom death is here can't run
what a fun bathroom all right okay who's
gonna scare me first
eeny meeny miny moe catch a tiger by the
toe Eddie hollers let him go gonna flush
it bone down a toilet
all right see you guys I'm gonna go
upstairs whoo very okay whoa nope not
ready for that okay what's in here
hello aah is that the outline of whose
bone this belongs to excuse me can I get
that
thank you small safe key you want this
thank you thank you so much
whoo I wonder where this goes I hidden
the gun in the prison cell
you mean the prison cell I was just in
okay
hit a gun in the prison cell so there's
it wonk it now well nevermind how about
you screwing whoa it's an old revolver
with only one bullet left wonder when
I'm gonna use that one got a gun I'm
ready for you okay well now what why did
I need a gun I need a gun I could use it
as a very short-term source of light if
I shoot a bang II then I'd see something
right that's how it works
that's how it works okay whatever
so I need some source of light maybe I
could rig this bone up with some cloth
and earn it
like if I rig if I rig my my rig is
bowling up with these scraps of clothing
from this mysterious dead body can I
shoot anybody anybody wanna get shot
maybe if I condense the methane from the
poop still remaining in these toilets
then I could possibly light a fire
womp screwdriver gun on door no I
thought gun on door was gonna work for
sure well I guess not
how about over here can i Blanca
are these boxes Blanca bull guys
shooting this tube I'm at a loss
scoochie alright and maybe I could block
this chair for some firewood nah alright
[Music]
well I am lost
oh wait whoa whoa whoa whoa where well
word what happened kay another victim by
the infamous with mr. whiskers last
Thursday night Dutch salesman Alexander
Witt has been taken from his home just
as the previous kidnappings a dead mouse
in a blank note has been found at the
crime scene this is the 14th victim
taken by mr. whiskers
a local witness was able to take a vague
picture of mr. whiskers oh thank you
what is that the Loch Ness monster is
mr. whiskers a UFO what's going on here
with this picture huh oh this day and
age 1988 they don't exactly have the
technology with which to make a better
picture I heard that also I questioned
the conundrum of leaving a dead mouse in
a world where cats and horses and stuff
real life day is that like a full-grown
like dead body to them is that look at
nothing personally Oh God not only did
he kidnap someone but also a dead body
murder kidnapping okay anyway see it so
that's interesting
I still can't see [ __ ] down here it's
awesome I say I think I think I saw
something I'm pretty sure I funcle' I
think II funcle' let me prep my gun go
away no I got a gun I don't want to
leave you be you'll trade me a list that
you don't know what is what for a gun
yeah Blanc you want a screwdriver maybe
if I tape the screwdriver to this bone
it'll look like a gun
[Music]
okay all right okay things to remember
saw two planks use eight nails board up
five windows keep one bullet in the gun
oh my god
[Music]
ah geez
that's [ __ ] awful well I have that
now wait Oh - eight five one for the
code okay why do I have a bone all right
whatever
do five one okay
[Music]
okay yeah I don't trust you I don't
trust you
oh hi mr. Lou I'm beginning you think
that people don't actually I'm beginning
to think that people aren't actually
answering for morphic animals and
there's Bern know that what's this just
normal human bodies with animal heads is
that what people people are in this
world I don't understand
whoa all right I got a flow that 17 X 4
why do I need to remember that 17 X 4 y
remember that 17 X 4 y I don't know why
17 X 4 y 17 to the right 4 down oh thank
you for explaining it to me 17 to the
right 4 down 17 to the right 4 down
anything else I need to know in here
seems like that mask is all sewed up
oh I get it I get it okay all right so
mr. whiskers is doing some weirdness
with tying masks to people's faces 17 -
the ride for down 17 to the right 4 down
17 to the right 4 down
click Oh nope don't like this no nope
you want a pound oh you are now that I
know that you're just ours a bottle of
piss hi
ok alright I'm worried about this who
seems like a good spare tire just shut
up just like I'm trying to escape for my
life and I'm just like aah thunk thunk
still got some air in it I could buy
sell this boy like 50 60 bucks off of
this bad boy alright okay when I get out
of here I'm gonna be starting off with a
bonus so Jack seems to be an unusual
good condition uh unusual good okay so I
need to fix up a car to get out of here
that's the thing is the long in this
short so how long was that guy the the
dog guy in the dark just down here just
waiting for me saw me come down each
time but only decided to bark once I had
a flashlight all right well you have fun
of that I will see you later
what do I need oh I know what I need to
Jack ooh I need to jack this door
ah good Jaken Oh bad grasan okay all
right okay all right
find the watching fine you find us
dictionary that's not the right word my
insult did not come across myself
this gate is protected by electricity oh
that I thought those fireflies that's
electricity okay alright whatever you
say
sure all right what's down here I wonder
I wonder a drain I wonder I wonder
anything in the corner there anything's
floating around here all right find the
watching I don't know what the watching
is but okay he is hiding is he watching
I'm trying to find the watching Sam he
must have something to do with 4017 to
the right four down
it's gotta have something to do with
that cool
what did I just try to put a tire in the
mirror I'm a freaking idiot Oh God
I don't to break a legs yes you're okay
is there any place here that I could
have done anything to do with a
coordinate sound you know the right four
down wait oh wait no here ah ah 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
15 16 17 4 Hey
oh that's a terrible key I don't like
I've regret picking that up but I have
that now okay all right well I know what
door this goes to magically and
wonderfully all right here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
the watching that sick bastard is
watching us for his eyes the bore man
where's uh where's the bore man wait
where's the borning can I see where the
Borman is nope I don't know where the
bore man is okay well I guess I'm gonna
find the poor man or man poor man okay
all right okay
okay funk plank funk useless junk coffee
that's hardly useless junk from my
experience coffee fixes all my problems
nice nice nice
thanks okay bore man hello well yeah
that that's a thing I just got useless
junk funky funky hide from this bore man
pump it on me
what would I make too much noise thunka
thunka lunk alright squeaky squanchy oh
that's not good
Oh Oh No
I've been through this before no no it's
now last before outlast happened returns
oh boy oh boy okay well alright we've
got shoes uh uh screwed ever get screwed
screwed okay okay alright this not going
nowhere
alright how about oh yeah this honor
yeah we're really squawking you got a
really I said you got a really squonk a
key key key all the keys no Jesus
this really is God it's a secret passage
is it really
oh okay nice key what did you do this
key all right well anyway
all right flug yeah this game really is
like a precursor it's this game came out
like 2014 like before any of this stuff
that I'm like getting deja vu from which
is super weird all right okay yeah yeah
boy man see ugly that is your ugly ugly
oh that's his house okay now I know
where he lives in case I need to come
back okay all right where am I Oh funk
gotta hide uncle uncle uncle maybe I
could flush it yeah oh that's it problem
oh here the solution know what's going
on okay you got a bucket guys I've got a
bucket anybody want to see my bucket can
I fill it up here this is where I could
okay so this
yeah could flush the drain with some
water okay Lu would be whoop oh man i'm
total i'm getting lost to where I am
okay well that's the thing now moving in
the trash cans woo only open from the
other side you say okay well okay well
that's a way out I think or released a
way around so I gotta do something to
fix all this [ __ ] hey can you donate
some fluids could you donate some fluids
please some sweet fluids all right I see
ya
friend yeah yeah so I'm thinking it as
something to do with this I mean there's
obviously like a leak there so ooh wait
no I know I can get back and then if I
go back I can uh there's water elsewhere
Road hmm there's water elsewhere right
wouldn't there be ooh can I get some
water maybe the kitchen why does all the
bathroom that's right here yeah
okay I have to go a long way back but I
got that good thing I remembered seasons
all right look excuse me Barbara and
sorry for being away for so long I do
apologize greatly lungful okay the
object must be downstairs probably okay
I think is I think that was a drain over
by mr. ugly oh yeah oh we care pin could
be used as a lockpick all that trouble
for a how did I know how could I tell
what universe did that make sense all
right whatever let's pick this log that
didn't work okay
wait no the gate yeah okay okay I'm on
the right track I'm on the scooty do
there's some fuel left in it okay all
right okay all right well apparently I
got nothing to graveyard even better
there's some fuel left in that graveyard
yeah doesn't seem to be dug a long time
ago
at least they had the common courtesy to
bury them after they murder them or Oh
devil is here no don't like that again
not good omens you're sprawling out for
me useless junk devil with yeah thank
you thank you for that thank you nothing
but human remains graves for a wonderful
wonderful okay no I'm gonna go with no
how about knows my response is that on
that good adequate nothing remains done
by human Marines that was awful that was
worth all the emotional scarring I
believe from that venture alright anyway
not gonna take the flowers I guess All
Right see ya everybody's yeah I got a
key another key no alright I'm I'm an
idiot okay her and I'm full this wait
did I go yeah no poor man safe okay okay
well that's weird why are you there no
Borton the password is no poor man named
ro bone
a fast safe I don't know okay all right
I'll be back I know where would this key
be to there was uh there was that other
door that I tried to pick a lock time
okay all right
fish love it love it oh oh oh oh fish
let's love it I don't love it as much I
love it not don't do that please stop
everything you're doing is horrible
that's our human leg in there why is
anything anything in this entire place
okay you know what I should leave that's
what I should do I don't know why I was
hanging around to be perfectly honest ah
nice and refreshing ah well that's not
what I wanted okay so I'm going back
around good god what is going on here
well alrighty then
can I Blanc him with a shovel
si si bar man sir dude sorry Nora oh
hello mr. cat nibbles I expect you to
take care of the mouse plague in my
kitchen please hurry up my restaurant
opens in two days time regards mr.
cotton fish what kind of weird world do
we live in
again I just want to say no and then
walk away from the situation because
that's the only logical conclusion when
you're approached with that conundrum no
no I won't do it I refuse ok let's see
what's up the lighthouse saw something
out of the corner of my eye
sorry I'm a little spooked ley reveals
need battery that's okay that's that's
what I need that's okay all right then
well haha go get you a snack
some that's not fish how about nice boar
I bet you'd like that okay
no fish huh no fish
all right human leg would you like human
leg
I got a nice human leg hmm
whew seems to be a mouse living in there
oh I know how to fix a mouse problem hmm
so I need something to attract the mouse
but I what do I have I don't have
anything there's no real food here this
is human leg I don't know so I need
something to be able to get that mouse
out of there but I'm not a hundred
percent sure what have I seen anything
have I seen like some cheese no no what
gets a mouse out I guess oh come on you
boarded that [ __ ] half-hour you
[ __ ] frickin bag of ass would you
like it nice I don't have a flashlight
in here anymore apparently I forgot I
guess no okay that's weird so if things
changed here has anything else changed
god I don't know
[Music]
no nothing Oh No there was a mousetrap
right there oh oh I was wandering around
for like forever Oh got it okay well his
instantaneous results are care right
there I'm off I'm off to the races give
me a battery please you gonna eat that
or you could just go look at it all
right yeah you doesn't like to eat in
privacy I guess right okay all right
well I got a battery okay what did it do
what did it do all right what is it
shining on right now is the question
right something outside it would be
shining upon something through here
something over here here in the
graveyard hello
no there's a lot more light right now
but why so that light has to do
something there's something very
specific with the light right is it
there was another area that was dark
wasn't there wasn't there it's gotta be
something like back right it would have
to be Thanks don't like that well the
lights shining here too so maybe there's
maybe there's something to this right
wait the hallway no but here close right
something around here something here I'm
getting closer to the truth maybe it
really was maybe it really was down
there nah too dark okay but it might be
something more there's a lot of light
here right now not crazy crazy
was that what kind of [ __ ] is that
deadmau5 oh okay all right you talking
about the musician that's all you're
talking about the password all right
okay all right there's a dead mouse a
dead mouse dead mouse who's a dead mouse
is it I think it's dead mouse dead meows
I don't know what that means what the
hell does I mean did I actually have to
click on it or something whoops I had to
click on it or I did I did I did
fine fine fine fine fine friend hi
friends don't make any trouble pal
okay all right you you you you do you do
buddy okay all right my Luger dear sales
I can reach there by was a shovel now
screwdriver all right fine
hello maybe I'm just smarter than you
maybe I didn't get caught by the bar man
maybe I was just a little quicker on the
drug do you know what I'm saying
oh okay all right so what are you guys
doing down here anyway he's just
chilling hanging out how do you get food
all right
you know I thought you were gonna be
cool you had a nice character design but
then you came out with a pun not only
that but you came out screaming with a
pun it wasn't just a normal pun you were
screaming it alright fine then
oh it's amazes it
damn this game is long actually I didn't
even realize she a tunnel will you
straight to this which one you're
standing next set to this one no okay
not that one I guessed and I was wrong
oh no wait I was right ah I see how we
do here ah got it
nailed it what did i do what did I do ah
okay
beware outside
all right okay well deadmau5 oh I get it
all right it's not smart to let the bar
man notice me okay no that's a senpai I
don't want on my back okay fine then
that's a little crooked all right what
else we have here
how about do the right no I do not thank
you very much why why are they on the
house that doesn't that's a strong drink
that's a strong drink okay all right
well I got that then that's nice free
drinks a ass gone for 10 years no
silicon to skate this sheit rule 10
years 10 years 10 years are you kidding
me no I don't wanna I'm trying to solve
a puzzle here don't you know
can't you take those things off of your
head I get I guess not with the bore man
being all serious about this stuff how
do they live here how does this work
how does society carry on okay dammit I
didn't mean to drink that no I'm not
hang on wait hang on I gotta go get
another beer let's see thanks thank you
what if I
what would I do with this I can't
exactly like use it because I just don't
click on stuff I'd have to click on it
right
ah there was a back area oh okay all
oh hello hi how you doing boy yeah huh
me what to gets out of here and help me
laughs okay yeah what a kid on this boat
for that one it's almost done
I just I do I swear I know how to get it
I know how to do that why won't you get
some squares ah nice dang well alrighty
then I got some bills alright knock the
people all right I see you
I got a shuttle I'll shovel you good
alright fine then see ya well that
walrus is dead no that's a dread walrus
okay I gotta go get the gas can and then
I got a knock everybody out in the
sleeping room I know how this works I
know what's going on here hey trust you
me I know exactly
Thanks alright I know exactly what's
going on here okay got the Jerry can let
me go to the room back here
you want these no no can't escape this
Shh oh I know what to do ah now that's a
strong drink so now put put it put it
down put Bridget Day there we go okay I
know what to do now now that I got the
Jerry can I knock out a mr. Bower man
and get the fuel and
out of here which just means that I'm
gonna die because the cap man is
probably taking care of the other guy
yeah all right so go here go here go
through here through here dude Ludi just
gonna leave this I want that you want
that sure see my instinct was right but
my execution was flawed I know there was
only one of them that needed to be put
to sleep in that other one because one
of them was already sleeping I get it I
get it I'm a smart cookie there you go
oh no okay well I get all right maybe
that comes later because god damn it I
keep thinking I'm right and I'm wrong
but anyway I got the gas so let's just
go for it I guess my instinct was right
execution blood just slightly flawed see
I know what I'm on about I know what I'm
on about I am gonna sleep sleeping like
a baby goat all right why did you steal
that gay dammit
let me sleep data I'm trying I'm trying
to get out of here man all right here we
go
now I bet walrus guy is now very dead
there's just an instinct nope I'm gonna
go with no hey gorilla man you might
want to run oh he is already out of he
okay well that's not good Hilary by the
pool that night he wants you
your safety procedures oh well I am
boned okay said I can't turn these off
well alright walk through driver key
want some booze don't know what to give
you
well ain't this a conundrum is as
conundrum as as they come
uh-huh okay all right
ah there we go hey happy birthday okay
damn that yeah Oh dad the mouse well
those [ __ ] are gonna whoops
well sorry thank you oh I got the keys I
know right let's get out of the shiny
mess once okay
then it worked are we free forever that
was a terrible vacation ah not over is
it well that was fast where the
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what a silly Billy
anyway that was really really good I
love that a lot and honestly all of the
solutions I was thinking about things
too in-depth the solutions were always
nearby where the problem was first
arisen so that was awesome
let me know what you think down the
comments below thank you everybody so
much for watching I'll put a link to
this game down in the description and
like I said it was made a long time ago
so honestly it's really interesting to
see how this kind of like skirted over
everything I've never I've never even
heard of this so anyway thank you again
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]